where are you at
is it early for you oh no it's late for
me actually
i'm in italy what yeah do you live there
i do for now yeah you do for now
for now yeah i'll be coming back to the
us at some point but um
yeah i'm in italy are you working on a
gig or you're just having fun
uh well this week i'm having fun but i
am working on a gig i'm editing
borderlands
so i have oh in italy i i i'm in italy
my editor's in la
but we do it all remote now so at a
certain point i'll go back to la for
you know probably fine tuning and temp
mixing and stuff for previews but
it's there's a new system like base it's
basically like zoom where you can hook
it up to a large television and it's
like you're in the room with your editor
so
trying it out i've talked to a lot of
filmmakers that have been using it over
uh the pandemic and been editing it's
been it's crazy the stories i've heard
yeah everything everything changed in
the pandemic i mean making a movie the
panda because the whole we'll do many
more interviews about that at some point
look i
thank god i shot finn before the
pandemic because i never would have been
able to film
what i got before um but we we were
cutting during the pandemic remotely i
mean we had to
so yeah i have a lot of questions about
finn
um i want to ask a few things first but
i'm just going to start with finn
that was a it was a first of all
congrats on the movie um
anything that can shine a light on this
despicable trade
is fantastic and uh i wanted to talk to
you and help you promote this
because of how strongly i feel that this
is something that needs
light on this very dark practice um
you know just so thank you i mean i i i
know it's also it's a tough subject
and it's hard to get people to care
about sharks and then they think well
sharks want to eat us why do we need
them
and when you see what's happening to
them you just it's it's unbelievable
especially when you realize that the fin
literally has no taste it actually is
filled with bleach and neurotoxins
the meat has more than 30 times the
allowable amount of mercury it's like
terrible
terrible for a human body the cartilage
pills that are sold at gnc and on amazon
inflame your joints
and the shark liver oil that's used in
cosmetics and makeup
has a cheaper plant alternative so
there's literally no reason
you're like oh yeah it's greed because
people are getting rich off the death of
sharks and then
people go well it's just china and no on
the east coast every weekend there's one
this weekend just google monster shark
fishing tournament
people are killing them they go well
it's just a couple of sharks but the
problem is
it's 300 boats every weekend on the
atlantic and the only sharks they're
taking out are the ones that are old
enough to reproduce so
basically they don't stand a chance
unless people just stop buying
shark yeah i i i'm gonna ask you a
question which um
and maybe i could be completely wrong
about this but i listen i love the movie
jaws
love it i think it's love it movies
phenomenal there's nothing wrong with
that movie
perfection and also a change the summer
blockbuster for hollywood it
like that movie is a significant part of
of hollywood but i also have to ask do
you think it's
a little bit possible that that movie
has also damaged
people's perception of sharks because it
you know sure it did and peter benchley
said
if he knew we actually had this quote at
the movie at some point if he knew the
damage his book would have caused he
never would have written it
because benchley learned how wrong he
was about shark like you watch the
trailer says it is a mindless eating
killing machine
people believed it they didn't know i
mean so now it but that's not why
they're being killed though it's too
easy to blame jaws
why they're being oh no i'm not blaming
jaws i'm just good but what i'm saying
is it goes in and people go well the
jaws are the perception of course jaws
did
but part of the problem is that also the
media fed into it because it's a great
story for them when someone gets hit by
a shark
no one's going to do a story of a shark
did nothing today a shark sat in the
water that's what they're doing
99 points that's what they all they're
doing all the time but that one time you
know seven people a year
in the world are getting bitten by
sharks or you know there's seven people
that die there's more you know but more
people are killed by armed toddlers but
the story is
shark attack they use the word shark
attack they're not attacking they
investigate with their mouths they're
biting and releasing they're not eating
us
the problem is that the fishing industry
loves it the fishing industry feeds the
media because it sort of allows everyone
to turn a blind eye to the fact that
shark species
since 2000 2 billion sharks have been
taken out of the water
and we don't know what our planet looks
like like our kids are not going to have
sharks
and they're going to have algae blooms
and this i mean they keep the ocean
clean
and the ocean makes half of our oxygen
and then you when you see
it's like wait so that some rich
organized crim some criminals are
getting rich off
is that why we're doing this so
restaurants can get rich off this what
that these false these health companies
that are
it's a complete lie the science about oh
if you eat a shark you won't get cancer
it's it's nonsense
it's like it's push starts get cancer
and so we show in the documentary how
all of this
basically they'll go well go watch jaws
and then don't bother us
i think that one of the things in your
documentary does talk about this
is the fact that it's not it's really
not a black and white issue
because the problem is you have people
let's just use
part of your film in mexico you have
people that are you know
going after sharks to fit you know going
after the fin
killing sharks because this is the
easiest way for them to make a lot of
money
in a short period of time so the problem
is
that you have all these communities that
are you know uh
basically we need to find a way for
these people to
make a living without here's here's the
answer
literally there's two beaches there's
cabo pomo and directly next to it is los
frieles now los frailis is where we film
the adjacent beach the one that borders
it is protected
the entire village flipped to dive
tourism and you go there
and everyone's in nice houses with air
conditioning and boats like the entire
place exploded where all these surfers
all these divers if you fl
they say that in the bahamas they're
protected a shark
dead one time used is worth about
probably about 30
or a shark alive over the course of its
lifetime in the bahamas
brings in thousand dollars in dive
tourism
so if you can help these villagers so
that's what reggie domingo in the movie
is doing in those fridays we're like how
can we there's a girl shark row madison
madison stewart she goes to indonesia
going
guys we got why you're doing this
they're going to be gone in 10 years
like really really gone
but if we can flip to dive tourism the
same shark that you kill once for 20
can be worth 200 000 for your village
so we need i mean there's got to be
programs there's got to be sponsors i
mean look
i think how much money we spent on
defense and all these insane things if
we helped these villages
that's why we can't vilify the fishermen
we have to get them on our side you
can't go
we have to go look 30 years ago i get
the white yes you do a monster shark
tournament
it's been going for 30 years but
whatever 30 years ago this wasn't a
problem
now it's a problem so we all have to go
well and i said to them like
why wouldn't you just do a shark dive or
shark tourism or take people out if you
charge people
bring them out on your boat chum the
waters look at the sharks put on a
snorkel jump in the water with them
you can do it that's why you know
there's a the dive rhode island joe
romero's partner
they the guy used to be a fisherman and
he switched to dive tourism
and it's it's endless it's evergreen so
that's what we need to do is we need to
help
people see that it's not just oh if you
stop fishing
everyone will you know lose their shirts
no if you can help
if we can find ways to educate and help
the fishing villages that are killing
them
turn to dive tourism so many people want
to get in the water with them
yeah what here's the thing that i think
a lot of people always want to know
it's very all all these problems exist
on the planet and
and again i'm so happy that you're
shining a light on this particular issue
but i think for everyone in like their
everyday life
they always are wondering how can i make
a difference what can i do
today that can help this problem so what
do you
what do you want to let people know so
easy and this is what i wanted in the
movie i wanted solutions i didn't want
to go well we're screwed what are we
going to do
first while we were making a movie the
shark fin sales elimination act passed
the senate and is now going to the house
so on findthemovie.com at the very top i
go if you're in the u.s
push here it's a letter you can copy
paste it
there's no one petition button you have
to go to there's a drop down menu this
is your rep
type in your zip code there's your rep
and their email and you paste the email
you write them going please support the
sharkman sales elimination act
everyone can do that easily and they can
have five friends do the same thing
in the eu we have one for a stop fining
in the eu that's a petition
they need a million signatures they're
about 236 thousand
um the other thing is that you can
demand places be shark free you can
tweet
to amazon go please stop selling shark
products you can
write to the makeup companies going is
your squalene shark liver
why don't you get the plant alternative
plant squalling is cheaper
stop buying shark you can go to gnc and
go why are you selling shark if you're
in florida
go into the public supermarket and go
what is this fish what is
atlantic whitefish what is what is
rockfish what do you it's what is this
non-specific fish
and when they say it's shark go why are
you selling this this is so poisonous if
people use their voice and their dollars
that's gonna we've got to drive the
price to zero it's the twofold of
having the politicians pass protection
laws but really
really what's gonna stop it it's like
the whaling industry you stop
buying it and we don't realize that all
of the shark
cartilage pills all the shark liver oil
look for squalling and makeup
look for fish in supermarkets and just
tweet you know hashtag
shark free demand that everything be
shark free like we demanded like look we
protected orcas they got sea worlds
you know they got the laws changed in
california 50 years ago the whole world
came together to protect whales
and i think it's just educating people
and also being understanding you know i
think that
in this thing of like we're going to ban
your business and ruin you i don't think
that's the attitude that any of us can
have i think we all have to say you know
what
here we are however we got here is how
we got here but we need the fishing
industry
we need the health industry challenge
them ask them to join our cause
and and take the pledge to make their
product shark free and by the way wild
aid has a whole bunch of programs
if you go on their website where you see
that like wilde and on finn the movie we
link to everybody
there's a lot of places you know fedex
is shipping shark fins or other places
the airlines that are shipping shark
fins so
you can write to the airlines but please
stop shipping it so once we start
once people start getting vocal about
not allowing the fins not allowing the
car the liver oil not allowing the
cartilage not wearing shark jewelry
all of that stuff but really right now
we have a moment
to write to your rep and that's the best
thing you can do i'm not gonna lie here
the movie's a tough watch i can't
i i have a very tough time watching
animals uh
um be her you know being hurt was there
any footage that you had that you're
like this is actually
i can't show this this is this is
horrible
i mean what i saw at that fishing
tournament in boston in new bedford my
you know
boston is where i grew up on my hometown
where they allow the scientists from
noaa the
government organization they go please
come and take the samples of the sharks
and they know people go well they're
killing sharks anyways we can get good
samples and get good data
and then they go see we're doing this
for science like they use the no
scientists get used
when i saw them scooping out the eyes
and then the guy takes the saw
that's why i cut it to the cannibal i
put the cannibal call holocaust music
inks i was like what else
can you do except use that music like
when else use it
they're hacking it off with a handsaw i
mean there was stuff that it was just it
was so much and it was actually
you know you know leonardo dicaprio was
really helpful he goes eli
he's like look i know you have the
highest tolerance available of gory goes
we need it to be education and not
like animal torture and we need to show
enough that people get the point
but if you show just a little bit more
people are going to go i can't finish
the dock and we want people to watch it
to the end so i think it has to be tough
enough that it stays with you so that
you want to do something
but not so strong you're just like
drained watching you know
sharks get hacked up for 90 minutes and
that's by the way why the movie took
so long to get was finding that balance
and the editing i mean we had other i
mean there's a whole section that paul
hilton the photographer shot in surabaya
in indonesia where there's just like
he's in this warehouse with just
just thousands of dead sharks and it
just like we had it but we thought how
is this more powerful it's not different
enough from liberia or mexico
or new bedford or anything else we shot
we just couldn't
you know we just couldn't use it but it
did get to be too much and it's very
very dip for me as a director watching
the stuff
for years and years was was really
difficult and it never got easier
but i just kept saying this has to be
out there if there's one i just want
that one record
that for the rest of my life the rest of
our lives people can point to and go you
know that thing about you just watch
this movie you'll understand it
and then hopefully one day the film
becomes irrelevant if i've really done
my job
the movie becomes like a work of science
fiction one day people go whoa we used
to do that
that's the goal with the movie it's for
yeah be like what the hell is this
yeah the thing about it is that uh i
so unfortunate that people are so
short-sighted on
so many issues whether it be climate
change sharks
overfishing the list goes on and on and
it really comes down to
i don't want to say greed sometimes it's
survival but it's just we have to as a
planet
do so much better about thinking five
steps ahead
over what we're just doing this year you
know it's
it's also the idea that that you can do
all these things in honor of tradition
it's like well yeah i mean think of all
the horrible things that have happened
over the last 250 years that were
traditions for a long time that we don't
do anymore
um you know we used to hunt lions and i
mean people were like
sold to slaves like like there's there's
so many moments where
the human beings have to go wait wait
this is this is insane what are we doing
and then you look back and go how could
they do this how was this a thing
um and you know i think we have to do
that with sharks i think we have
like when you look back at whale hunting
and you know new bedford was a whaling
town
and now they're killing sharks without
any irony i'm like do you guys realize
that
your entire industry in this town was
wailing
and you flipped and you stopped killing
whales and the town thrived still and
life went on and everyone's fine like
our lives will be fine if without
killing we don't have to kill sharks to
have a happy fulfilled life
like we can be perfectly fine in fact
we're much better if we stop killing
sharks
the problem is that if if we're really
we're not supposed to interact with
sharks we're never supposed to see them
sharks aren't supposed to see us
we're not supposed to see them so yeah
you can go in the ocean but most of the
time
every time it's like think of all the
times you've been to the beach have you
ever seen a shark
most people say no well sharks have seen
you they're there the entire
time but you know they don't want
anything to do with us
so it's not like more of them will make
the waters more dangerous in fact it'll
create biodiversity and keep the oceans
healthy
um and you know we owe it to our
children we owe it to our children to
say what the hell are we doing we've
gotten it so wrong
we are the jaws generation and we owe it
to the future generations to
make this the tipping point when people
stop making sharks the villain and start
protecting them
they sharks do not have vocal cords we
are the only ones that can be
vocal cords for sharks as tough as it
was to watch finn
i'm so thankful you made it anything
that can shine a light as i said on this
horrible practice
uh i'm happy to help promote it on
collider thank you please have people
link to you know find the movie dot com
so they go here to help to help
contact the reps that's the way by the
way the movie is if if
people don't take action and take the
five minutes to write the rap
the movie's worthless like i really like
i mean i believe the movie has value but
i really think if if we don't do
something
the movie was made as a tool for
everyone to do something
and if people don't take action then
there's sort of no point i really
appreciate you making the movie
good luck with everything you're doing
and i look forward to seeing borderlands
in a year
i look forward to us having a full-on
discussion about it too
100 hey listen have a great day man
thanks buddy
bye